last night we were advised by public
health officials
in very stark terms that proceeding
exactly as planned on the 5th of july
carries a real risk of greatly increased
spread of the virus
increased hospital admissions illness
and death
last night and this morning the
government has examined this advice
and agreed to delay some elements of the
further reopening scheduled
for the 5th of july there will be an
increase
in the number of people attending
outdoor events
and given its very special nature the
numbers of guests attending weddings can
increase to 50 as planned
however a return to other indoor
activities
including hospitality will be delayed
nephit's clear advice based on the
modeling it has done
is that given the increased
transmissibility of the delta variant
the safest way to now proceed with
return to indoor hospitality
is to limit access to those who have
been fully vaccinated
or have recovered from covet infection
over the course of the coming weeks
government will work
urgently with the relevant sectors to
agree
a practical and workable approach
you